hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to dead bits a game that I
found on Steam and it seemed pretty cool
now I know that it is definitely gonna
be very cool so either way whoo I'm all
jazzed up from the history I'm very
interested oh my god is this dumpy going
elephants okay so this game is basically
oh Willy lived in a distant galaxy okay
some day alien species commanded by
Kuantan abducted sleep okay cool
now Quilly has to complete all Quantum's
tests in order to earn his real I am out
of breath from dancing into this video
so I hope you all appreciate how intense
that was for me I was just as intense
for you but either way it's like this
weird combination of things that I've
seen before okay so I really don't know
where to begin with this because it's a
first-person shooter based on a world of
blocks
oh you son of a [ __ ] you big bastard
boy yeah did I do it I think I did it
holy crap they exploded into pieces so
it's all based on blocks and I guess
that's similar to Minecraft in that it
uses blocks but I don't know what else
is similar to okay yeah I get
transported I don't know why but this
reminds me of oh cool I won I think I
really didn't intend for this to be as
uh-huh hey I'm still trying to adapt
here why is that red green and blue
blam oh I need to jump well fine then
yeah that's right oh you see you go home
yeah oh you bring your dead oh god I
fell in today oh good they're all gonna
be munching on my corpse for all of
eternity that's a nice sign all right
take two I'm gonna be toning back the
insane ometer right now because I need
to wrap my head around what's happening
here okay so this game is available on
Steam I think it was around five bucks
whether it's worth it is up to you but
it's got a bangin soundtrack ins
pre-breathe tight controls I guess you'd
call it all those are health bars above
its head whoa full motion I guess that
was worth it no idea what is going on
why the hell is quant on staff tests
have to do with these black zombies I
don't know but frankly I don't care I
find myself lost in a world where I am
obliterating some thumbs don't even try
it maze ah me
what is the hole Wow okay so anyway
still trying to wrap my head around back
this but it's so freakin awesome
I mean it's low res but it's stylized in
that way you get some you're not trying
to eat me oh that's my health bar at the
bottom and I like I like the fact that I
recognize the font that is portraying
here hi
no trees gonna block you from me do I
even have a mo here I know I do what's
going on but I love it oh I love
everything about ya
yeah you mini zombie bastards okay you
can get me I'm gonna switch to the other
one because there's actually probably
more effective
and picking them off from a distance
there we go explode in the blogs stay
away from me you bastards that's right I
don't even have to reload this sumbitch
I am that awesome god this is cool
I gotta admit when I was going into the
cells expecting to be underwhelmed
because obviously it's based off of
pixelated box graphics now whether it's
worth five bucks it's definitely up to
how long the game is and how much
variety there is to it
oh we're gonna find that out that's why
I play these games for you guys and give
them a look so you don't have to waste
your money that's part of the reason why
I do this oh is that a katana oh it's
just a baseball bat isn't it oh come on
this better be mind-blowing Lee amazing
or else I'm gonna be very upset is that
a boss wrong with your dinky little
speckles oh now oh it is so on and you
are so off because you just fell to
pieces okay so I did it good job oh god
this is gonna turn up oh I did not
expect this to turn horreur oh my god
Jesus I suddenly got that was why the in
the options menu I'll show you a little
snippet of it right now
in the options menu oops downright
terrifying I was wondering why I mean I
know it's the zombie gaming all but wait
you sons of [ __ ]
you scampering little green douches I'm
gonna smack you in the balls bloom smack
in the squares actually I guess would be
more appropriate for that hey hey so
some behind this wall that every wall
okay every wall does that no such luck
okay I'll go the one way that you tell
me to go
I feel like this got way off to a hugely
energetic start and I'm never gonna be
able to live up to that
but either way okay let's calm it down
here a little bit I am currently
wandering around in the sewers I'm
guessing trying to hunt down zombies
because that is part of my test
I was just taking a nice old now oh god
bad time for slo-mo why would you do
that why would you do that what is that
oh that's a hell thingy okay I need that
oh Jesus Oh stay away from me you smarmy
bastards
come here you give me a tastier medicine
or give you a me it tastes odd oh did I
go this way I'm not sure if I went this
way already or if I've already I don't
know I'm kind of confused I'm still
reeling from how this game started to
where it is now oh you want to send an
army after me huh take some of my
slow-mo action and really inconvenient
times it's trying to bash down all the
zombies don't need to see him die in
slow-mo say there was another one what
are you doing to me god I'm having high
blood pressure here because you're just
being a son of a [ __ ]
I'm not giving me a time to breathe so
just let me relax
it won't be good okay we're gonna be
just fine thank you I'm gonna complete
five tests that's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna leave the rest of that to your
decision it should give you guys a good
enough idea of what the game is going to
be you're not giving me a weapon right I
didn't I didn't get a weapon if you guys
could provide me with one of those I
would really appreciate it because right
now okay here it is got it you know how
in the beginning of this game he gave me
guns that was really cool can we bring
that back again oh I'm so happy when I
had guns and this game suck okay high
G's scampering [ __ ]
okay so motion good I like how you got
little block warts on your arm there
really yeah
those who Jerry that's me no you stay
back
Jesus stop it you're terrifying
you're legitimately terrifying I have
chills down my spine you were terrifying
please stop I just want to go about my
day without being terrorized by you
bastards don't be behind it
Oh God oh god the floors going out get
out of my way get out of my way the
floor is ending that's great I'm running
through you screw you guys gun no okay
I'm dead they're feasting on my corpse I
get it I failed
shut up jeez I didn't get my bat hold on
for two seconds oh it's real quick while
I get my bat smack in the face oh
they're dead you fell off you losers
[ __ ] you I'm gonna go on buy my business
where's my bat that I forgot to get but
I'm gonna get now all right
now that I finally got this under
control I can actually get some handle
on the situation either way this is a
charming game didn't expect it to evoke
this much emotion atomy those things are
coming is right down scary okay no I
can't telling there's one right behind
him does this all blocks get out of here
no no
you know you know you know thank you
it's just like to make my way to the gun
so that I can get out of here okay thank
you very much for being cooperative with
me and now I'm gonna be cooperative with
you by feeding you your daily dose of
bullets
please slow oh god I don't ever Oh God
I forgot oh he's not slow that guy he's
that guy he's anything but slow
that guy's but maybe slow I don't know
but I'm saying right now that I don't
want you sorry you're a sexy individual
but I do not want you knees just please
get out of my way oh god I do not
understand this game it is so simplistic
and yet this is causing me to panic more
than ever like many other games that I
played Jesus I don't even understand why
also the soundtrack is very good I got
to admit that
oh jesus sob stop stop stop no no no no
no no thank you thank you thank you no
no no no no no no no no no no no stop it
you're so fast it's not fair yeah yeah
yeah
do headshots even make a difference here
I am not entirely sure why are there
numbers in the ground I know what you're
gonna do you're gonna pop them up on me
I'm gonna make them pop up
nice try I need a jump nice try on you
I'm never gonna jump down there and look
at those sons of [ __ ]
damn I die no no no slow the biggest
slow oh god I'm not dead I thought it
was dead oh god I'm not dead that's what
I'm said oh good Jesus you son of a
[ __ ] hiding that health Bach from me
okay don't fall off the edge here I
really got to make it to the exit
you son of a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah
you Sambi bastard get some bullets to
the hole you got really dirty once you
die here your face looked rather silly
okay so I just gotta make it through
this jumping area so that I do not oh
god oh please please don't let me die I
went through all of that thank you okay
god damn that is so cool all right so
those dead bits I know I said I was
gonna do five but god that was way more
hectic than I imagined either way this
game was a lot of fun sorry it got crazy
in there but I didn't know what was
happening at the time but either way if
you think this is worth five bucks it's
got a great soundtrack but hey it's up
to you there may only be nine levels
here so anyway links in the description
check out the other awesome games that I
played over in the annotation over there
in the description below thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will se you in the next video